Sergei Magnitsky was a Moscow lawyer who
exposed mass fraud being carried out by
Russian tax officials in 2008 he was
arrested by the very people he accused
today some of the men involved in his
death were sanctioned by the British
government it is the first time that the
UK has announced a package of sanctions
specifically targeting human rights
abuses the list names 47 individuals and
two organizations from four countries
Russia North Korea Myanmar and Saudi
Arabia
how can your government continue to be a
key ally of saudi arabia's when
individuals such as the deputy head of
saudi intelligence and numerous advisers
to the crown prince are now in your
words being sanctioned because of gross
human rights violations
how can we continue to be friends with a
country like that I think the Saudi
quite right is holding to account
through criminal trials in that country
those responsible for the murder of
Khashoggi
and it's absolutely right that those
countries that have a sanctions regime
in place there's not that many but there
is a growing number like the UK are
willing to say in relation to
individuals that they will be designated
not allowed to come to this country I'm
not allowed to invest in this country I
think that's right and fit and proper
Sergei Magnitsky wife and son watched
the statement from the Foreign
Secretary's office along with his friend
and business client Bill Browder they
have campaigned for this law for 10
years what it does is it it effectively
creates a climate of fear among human
rights violators and kleptocrats like
Putin and like others because they all
do their crimes in their home countries
and then they want to travel and enjoy
the fruits of safe and lawful places
like the UK and this stops them from
doing that and and it also for those who
aren't sanctioned it puts the
uncertainty over them that they might be
sanctioned someday in the future if this
new human rights driven approach is to
be effective the British government will
need to be consistent in its approach
and it will need to be prepared for
counter sanctions that's one thing
against the likes of Myanmar
and North Korea but sanction China
though and you better be prepared for a
battle since brexit we've heard the
phrase global Britain a lot but no real
evidence of what that means the
government says that these new Human
Rights ank shion's are proof of global
Britain in action alistair bunker Sky
News at the Foreign Office